eating liver is not going to cause
vitamin a toxicity
and the studies done on vitamin a toxicity
were done using an isolated
synthetic version in supplement form
if the supplement bottle does not
label it as either beta carotene
or fish oil it's probably synthetic
the synthetic version being toxic
being a fat soluble vitamin
it needs to be accompanied
by other micronutrients
in order to be properly synthesized
by the body
and natural vitamin a really only comes
from animal based sources
so instead of trying to fill
the gap in micronutrients with
a cabinet full of synthetic
isolated supplements
why don't we just simply
go to the source and eat food